exasperación por la falta de suministro
de combustible Los afectados que hacen
largas filas para llenar sus tanques no
están de acuerdo con el sindicato
no no entiendo a los huelguistas en
absoluto sobre todo porque en total
energios ganan entre 3.000 y 5000 euros
son de los mejor pagados de la clase
Obrera y por eso los entiendo aún menos
pero entiendo perfectamente que a las
cgt le guste bloquear a la nación Ese es
realmente su trabajo Eso es lo que
entiendo de ellos
es terrible creo que es inaceptable
dejar los conductores así sin poder
utilizar sus vehículos hay atascos por
todas partes todo el mundo hace fila se
extienden durante kilómetros solo para
que uno pueda conseguir 10 o 20 litros
de gasolina es absolutamente inaceptable
estoy muy molesto Es que la huelga ha
hecho que la producción de gasolina en
Francia se haya reducido en más de un
60%. una de cada tres gasolineras en el
país presenta escasez
Será muy difícil es difícil el momento
para todos los médicos los bomberos es
muy difícil llevo cuatro días intentando
llenar el tanque de gasolina y mi coche
pronto se estropeará Así que espero
poder conseguirla Espero que las cosas
mejoren y que encuentren un acuerdo
a pesar de la decisión del gobierno de
obligar a los trabajadores para que
cumplan sus funciones otras empresas
energéticas han amenazado con unirse a
la huelga Como ya pasó con el grupo de
energía nuclear edf